[Music]
It's
God. It's God.
It's God.
>> Good.
>> Okay.
>> A7 A74 is a good one. Good.
>> Um, watch this.
>> Good question. Did Jesus worship one?
>> Did Jesus worship three gods or did he
worship one God?
>> He worshiped one.
>> One God.
>> Who was this one God? Because remember,
you believe God is not just God. You
believe God is father, son, and holy
spirit.
>> So, which one did he worship two? Yeah.
So you want to answer that?
>> Yeah. He worshiped the father.
>> Period.
>> He worshiped the father. Period.
>> Yes.
>> So he worshiped only the father.
>> Yeah.
>> He did not worship the holy spirit.
>> Well and when he's worshiping God in
worship with the holy with the father
that is by a product he worship the holy
spirit as well.
>> You just said he did not worship the
holy spirit. You just said he worshiped
the holy spir.
>> He didn't say he did not worship. We
never denied that he worship the holy
spirit.
>> I said he worshiped the father. His
denom. His direction of worship being to
the father is also byproduct by default
also worship to the holy spirit as well
because when you're worshiping god I'm
I'm telling you I'm telling you because
they're inseparable the the spirit
brother the spirit of the father the
spirit of god is inseparable from them
there's no separation the spirit of is
yahweh himself so when you're worshiping
let's say you focus your worship to one
person of the of the godhead if you're
worshiping one person still by default
that worship goes to the others as well
you're not excluding the others, but you
can highlight one particular person.
>> So that's what Jesus does. He highlights
or specifically talks to the father.
>> But Jesus is always referring to the
father. He's always praying to the
father. He doesn't pray to the holy
spirit. He even said the father is the
only one that knows the hour. The only
one that knows the hour. Meaning the
holy spirit doesn't know the hour
>> because the hol because the father is
not the holy spirit and the holy spirit
is not the father.
>> 2319 god is not a man. God is not a man
that he should lie neither neither the
son of man that he should repent. Is
that a good argument?
>> Hath he said it?
>> Is that a good argument?
>> Is that I get what he's saying?
>> No, I know. We all get what he's saying.
Is that a good argument?
>> I get what you're saying. And of course,
God is not a man.
>> Is this argument to you? I'm explain to
you.
>> Wait, wait. I want Adam. Adam. Is that a
good argument?
>> You got there's
how many arguments there are.
>> Father, the son of the Holy Spirit.
>> I got you, Adam. Is that a Is that a
good argument?
>> You don't let good subjective.
You know, that's a good one, right?
>> That was a good one, right?
>> Okay. I know. I know. That's a good one,
right?
>> All right. So, look, look, back to the
point.
>> Okay.
>> Who do you worship? The father, the son,
the holy spirit, or all three of them?
>> Yeah, I worship the father, the son, and
the holy spirit.
>> Did did Jesus ever worship the holy
spirit?
>> So, I just answered that. By worshiping
the father by default, he also that that
worship is also predicated to the
spirit.
>> Did you answer my question?
>> Yes.
>> No, you didn't. I asked you after that.
Where is the verse? Wait, are you asking
for where Jesus says, "Holy Spirit, holy
is your name?" Are you asking for
something like that?
>> Anything along those lines. Does he
pray?
>> So you're asking for something verbatim?
>> No. Anything along those lines does not
mean verbatim. So anything along those
lines. Anything within that.
>> I got you. So anything along anything
along those lines. If he's worshiping
the father, by default, that worship is
also predicated to the spirit because
the spirit is not separated from the
father. The spirit is one in essence
with the father.
>> So that means the father is the son. No,
it means that the father is the look the
father the father and the son listen the
father and the son are are materially
identical meaning they sh meaning I'm I
literally said meaning
they share the same substance they're
identical in their essence yet distinct
in their personhood so the father is not
the son in their person right they're
distinct hypoasis meaning they're
persons however when it comes to their
essence their substance they are
identical in the properties of what
makes God God. They have the same exact
properties.
>> This is all beautiful. But where where
does it say that in the Bible?
>> It says it all over. Look, it said look
for example um you would agree that God
is the first and the last. The alpha and
omega beginning again, right?
>> I mean Melix was that too, wasn't he?
>> No,
>> he wasn't the first and the last.
>> he wasn't. He didn't have a beginning or
end.
>> I'll say it again. The first the first
and the last. The title, the first and
the last. The beginning and the end, the
alpha and the omega. You would agree
that these are titles of God, right?
>> Did you didn't answer my question
before?
>> I did. I said no. Three times.
>> So Melzdc is not
does not have a beginning. MelzDC is a
finite being.
>> So now did he have a beginning? Now he
had a beginning. He's a finite being. So
notice I answered your question. Now
I'll answer this really quick and
hopefully you can answer mine. Okay.
I'll answer your question. All right.
With with with Melzdc, it's talking
about his record of life, right? So he
came up and he showed him out of
nowhere. In context is talking talking
about how he just appeared to Abraham
out of nowhere. They have no record of
his birth, no record of his death, no
record of his genealogy. He just
appeared and disappeared out of nowhere.
And it says resembling like the son of
God remains a high priest. So he's a
type of Christ, but he's not the Christ.
Amen. Nor is he uh uh uncreated. He's
finite, right? He's a human being, but
with special qualities or special
attributes that liken him to Christ as a
type or foreshadow. Okay. Amen. So now
with that answer, is the first and the
last, the beginning and the end, the
alpha and the omega, God himself.
>> Sure. Yeah.
>> These are these are attributes of God.
Sure.
>> Absolutely. So Jesus himself claims he
says, "I am the first and the last, the
beginning and the end, the alpha and the
omega. So there Jesus claims to be the
almighty God." Thereby saying that he is
in the same substance as the father
while at the same time being a distinct
person from the father. It wouldn't make
sense because then he's he's saying
other things that disqualify that.
>> Like what?
>> Like the father is greater than I. Like
um for example um him always praying to
the father. Him saying that I myself can
do nothing.
>> Did God die? Did God die?
>> Can can God die?
>> It depends on the kind of Christian.
Some Christians they'll say God died.
Some say it wasn't the godly nature. It
just depends. It just depends.
>> The point is this.
>> Again, we're going back to the signs,
right? At least one of the one that I
saw. What was the other signs that that
you have on?
>> Wait, you you did you want to what what
argument did you want me to address? You
just listed like a few like him praying
or saying
>> this is showing this is showing that
he's a messenger of God. He's a prophet
of God.
>> Okay. So he's the Christ,
>> right? And we have no problem with that.
So
>> but you but you then put him to another
level. Here's the difference. The Jews,
they disrespect Jesus. They say he's
burning in hellfire. They put him all
the way to the ground. The Christians
take Jesus all the way to the top. They
say he is God himself. The Muslims, we
come in balance. We come to the middle.
Sorry, it's again. And and and and and
it does not put Jesus to the almighty
God. Nor does it say Jesus is nothing
because we love Jesus. Jesus, we love
Jesus. Again,
>> I ask you, let me ask you this. Um do
you love your mother?
>> Of course.
>> You respect her?
>> Yes.
>> All right. What if you
>> I'll do my best to do so. I always do,
but I do my best.
>> All right. So, let's say you introduced
me to your mother, right? But the way
you introduced me was like this. You
said, "Hey, Avery man. Um I want you to
meet my good friend here. She's been
with me all my life. Really looked out
for me. Good woman. But don't mistake
it. She ain't my mother though. Is that
respectful to your mother?
>> If I say if I tell you that my mother is
not my mother, then sure. Yeah.
>> Is that respectful?
>> No. That would be disrespectful.
In the same way that by denying who your
mother is, even though you say good
things about her like she's a good
person, she raised you in your life and
all these kind of things, but if you
deny that she's your mother, if you deny
who she truly is, that is still
disrespectful. So what you what the
Muslims do is that you say good things
about Jesus like he was born of a
virgin. He's a great prophet, one of the
mightiest, he's even the Messiah, but
but you deny that he's the son of God.
You deny his divinity and you deny his
salvific mission. Meaning you meaning I
know meaning you disrespect Jesus
because you deny who he is. Just like
you will be disrespecting your mother if
you denied who she was
>> in your paradigm.
>> But objectively not in my paradigm.
>> Matthew 15:24 Jesus only came for the
Jew.
>> So So how so let me ask you this.
>> He said I I did not come for anything
but the
>> So let me ask you this. When Jesus says
that the father is greater than I, how
do you understand that? that the father
is literally greater than him.
>> In what way?
>> All right, let's put another verse
together. No, this verse.
>> No. How does he when you say
>> that the father is greater than Jesus,
greater in what sense?
>> All senses.
>> Okay.
>> All right. So, all senses. Okay. So, so
let me ask you this. If I were to say
>> Jesus, let me let me let me let me deal
with that. Jesus had a God.
>> Do you play any do you play any uh
sports?
>> Soccer. Yeah,
>> soccer. Okay. No, I suck at soccer. I
don't play soccer. But let let's say uh
play now let's say you know in in the
context of soccer but let's say I say um
you know uh Adam is greater than I
>> does that mean that you're a greater
human than I am?
>> No.
>> No. So we're equal in one sense but
you're greater than me in another sense.
Right.
>> Sure.
>> Okay. So what about Jesus saying the
father is greater than I tells you that
he's that that's talking about his his
essence?
>> He is simply God and Jesus is not. What
about that statement tells you that
>> by saying he's greater than him and with
more context again I can't cherryick
right
>> very good but you quoted this verse okay
so can we agree
>> I quoted multiple times
>> I got you so can we agree that there's
nothing in John 14:28 when Jesus says
the father is greater than I that says
that he's a lesser being than the father
>> what do you mean
>> that he's not God nothing in John 14:28
where Jesus where Jesus says the father
is greater than I in that statement says
that he's not God correct
That statement is clearly stating that
he's not God. Yes,
>> I got you. So when I say Adam is greater
than I, is that statement clearly
stating that I'm not human?
>> No, because you have to take everything
within context.
>> Exactly. So that's my question.
>> I'm all about No problem. So what in the
context of John? Matter of fact, let me
let me give you some context. In John
14, Jesus says, let's go to the back. He
says, "Believe in God, believe also in
me." He also says, right, continuing on,
he said, they say, "Show us the Father."
He says, "Have I been with you so long
and you haven't known me, Philillip?" He
says, "Don't you know that I am in the
father and the father is me in me? If
you have seen me, you've seen the
father." Here's my question to you. Can
a prophet claim if you've seen me,
you've seen Allah?
>> It's very simple. Very simple.
>> Yes or no?
>> The answer. Oh, you want you want answer
yes or no? No. Secondly, secondly,
secondly, no. Secondly, Jesus is saying
that his oneness with the with the
father is the same oneness when you go a
couple chapters afterwards when he's
saying that that oneness is the same
with the disciples. When he says, "Oh
father oneness,
>> he he says, "Oh father, that oneness
that we share." You're
>> talking about another argument, brother.
I didn't realize.
>> You're talking You're saying that that
one that oneness makes him go
>> say anything about oneness.
>> You said that him being one with with
God.
>> I I'll say it again. I said in John,
look, I'm I'm only dealing with John 14.
Remember, you quoted 28. I'm starting in
the beginning and I'm showing what you
Jesus said leading up to that. Okay? So,
I didn't say Jesus said I and the father
are one. That's another chapter.
>> In this chapter, he says, "If you've
seen me, you've seen the father." Now,
my question is this.
>> Are you saying that's literal?
>> Of of look.
Is it literal? Hold on. Hold on. No. Is
it literal? You're cutting me off. You
me in corners.
>> I did. Can I answer you?
>> Is it just answer is does that mean
literal?
>> Absolutely. When you see Jesus, you see
the father. Why? Because he is the
express image of the father's essence.
The Bible says that he is the exact uh
he's the exact representation of the
father's nature. So when you see Jesus,
you're seeing a visible image of the
invisible God. That's that's literal. So
look now now listen wait. I I I was
getting to mind you coming up with that
question. So So here look listen to
this. So with this question, look, you
said you said that no prophet can ever
say if you've seen me then you've seen
Allah. Why?
>> Cuz you cannot see Allah.
>> Yeah. So
>> just as just as the Old Testament says,
you cannot see God.
>> Very good. So what is so what would it
mean? Wait, if a if a prophet was saying
if a prophet said I if you've seen me,
you've seen Allah, would that be
blasphemy? Again, you have to take it
all within context just as you say.
Jesus like anything that Jesus is saying
there he's clearly who is it Thomas was
it Thomas or Philip was not trusting
Jesus. So he's saying how you not going
to trust me you want to see God he's
basically pushing him away on that and
telling he's
>> he said you want to see God look at me.
>> So that means literally
>> you want to look at God look at me. So
that's what he said.
>> So I asked you a straight question.
>> I asked you one you didn't answer.
>> All right. What's your question then? My
question is if a prophet said, you said
a prophet can't say that,
>> correct?
>> And I asked why. You said cuz you can't
see Allah. My ne my question was would
it be blasphemy if a prophet said if
you've seen me you've seen Allah?
>> Sure. Just like there's many blasphemous
verses in the Bible.
>> Very good. Notice this now man.
Beautiful point. Look. He said no one
has answer my question. I I promise you
I'll get to it. I promise I'll get Let
me land this. Notice this. Notice how we
built here. You agreed with me that this
statement from Jesus is blasphemous,
right? Meaning that he's claiming to be
an associate with God. He's claiming to
be on that same level. If you've seen
me, you've seen God. So, a prophet can't
say that from your paradigm because you
understand that this is a claim to be
God. So, I'm telling you that before you
get to verse 28 where Jesus says the
father and is is greater than I, you get
a verse where Jesus is claiming equality
with the father. So in context, Jesus is
in no way saying that he is of lesser
essence than the father. However, it's
another sense. Jesus is equal with the
father. As he said, if you've seen me,
you've seen the father. However, in
another however, however, in another
sense, because Jesus is the humble
servant of the father, he humbles
himself to the father. Therefore, in
that way, the father is greater than I.
Not in essence, but in role.
>> Which nature? Which nature humbled
himself?
>> What are you talking about? Which
nature? Natures don't do anything.
>> What do you mean? You wouldn't you
wouldn't say Jesus's divine nature
humbled himself to God?
>> No, I would say Jesus humbled himself to
God pertaining to nature which nature
you don't believe Jesus Jesus. You
believe you believe Jesus as a human and
Jesus as God because he has two because
he has uh two natures. So correct me
correct me if I'm wrong. Let me Yeah. So
let me tell you why the question is
wrong.
>> Because you're you're assuming when you
say which nature submitted right humbled
himself to the father which
>> so that's implying that natures act.
>> Natures don't act. Persons act. Persons
do things. Okay. So your human nature
doesn't do anything. Adam does right?
You just possess a human nature. So when
we say it's Jesus that submitted to the
father. We don't say so then why do
Christians when when I when we tell them
Jesus didn't know the hour? Oh, that's
his uh human nature
>> because okay, look, if you're talking
about if you're talking about that
particular interpretation, no, you got
to understand what I'm saying. Nobody's
saying that uh natures do anything or
nature's act. Nobody's saying that there
are there are properties. Yes. Yes. He
knew the hour. Yes. He knew all things.
John 16:30. Uh we got a Bible. Let's get
Hey, what we doing?
>> John 16 difference between nature and a
person.
>> John 16:30. Right there. There's no
difference between nature and
interaction.
If I look, if I was if I was a DA guy,
bro, I would be clowning you, but I'm a
Christian. I love you. So, I'm not I'm
not like trying to
>> The Muslim Diab would go clown me.
>> No. If I was a DA guy, I would be
clowning you on what you just said. You
just said that persons and natures on
the same thing. down people would have
me they would help me help me
like a look at this muscle me
ignorant now now you're ignorant now
it's two colors to show
it now you're clown now you're a clown
bro my muscle brother would never do
that I love you too
brother
>> John 16:30 random
Adam John 16:30
>> I'm the war this is right after John 14.
So two chapters later. Now we know that
you know all things and do not need
anyone to question you. This is why we
believe that you came from God.
>> What was the first word?
>> Wait, what did you say?
>> Now. Now.
>> Yeah.
>> Did he have it before?
>> Of course.
>> So this this is something this is
something the disciples are realizing.
The disciples are saying now we know you
know all things and believe that you
came from God. And hey, watch what Jesus
wait watch Jesus says. He doesn't say
hey. Don't say that. He doesn't he
doesn't say that. Watch what he says.
How does he respond
>> in verse 31?
>> Verse 30.
>> I mean, he would use that same exact
word for something else, but he would
use it.
>> Verse 31. Verse 31. Do you now believe?
>> Oh, so he doesn't say
don't say that. He doesn't say
don't do that.
>> You need to understand again the
context. He was given all authority, was
he not?
>> Wait, what does this have to do with
that's not in the context, bro? No, the
context is in Jesus telling
>> if he knows if Jesus knows anything,
it's because the father gave it to him.
If he does anything, it's because the
father did it.
>> All right. So, let's say this. Can we
Can we agree that according to the Bible
and to Jesus, he knows all things based
on what we just read? Yes.
>> Say say that one more time.
>> Can we agree that according to the text,
Jesus knows all things? Yes.
>> Oh, he did not know all.
>> He did not know the hour.
>> We we just read the verse.
>> 1332.
>> 13:32.
>> Okay. So, let's do it again. 13:32. Mark
13:32.
>> All right.
>> Jesus did not know the hour. We're going
to read the read the verse one more
time.
Brainwash.
The disciples say his disciples said,
"Now we know that you know all things."
>> Stop there. Wait.
>> Did you hear that?
>> Mark 13:32. Mark 13. Did you hear that?
Jesus did not know. Okay. Did you pay
attention, bro?
>> Now we know that you know all things.
>> Pause. Did they understand that Jesus
knows all things?
>> Sure. Okay. And then how did Jesus
respond?
>> Do you now believe? So does Jesus affirm
their belief that he knows all things?
>> Sure.
>> Okay. So according to the Bible, can we
agree that Jesus knows all things?
>> Again, at the end of the day, whatever
he knows is the father. They gave it to
him.
>> Brother, can we agree? No worries. I'll
go with you. Can we agree to according
to the Bible, Jesus knows all things?
Again, you're doing you're what you're
doing here is you're just pick taking
one single verse just as I can say.
Okay. Okay.
>> Is is is God a man?
>> Is God is the same thing?
>> According to the verse,
>> can we agree according to the verse?
>> I hope y'all
>> love you too. Love you too, bro.
>> I love you guys.
>> Hey, may you meet Jesus one day,
brother. Yo, when Jesus comes and tells
you guys, we warned you guys. We warned
you guys. going to be the antichrist.
>> That's going to be the antichrist
going to say, "Hey guys, I'm a Muslim.
I'm the Messiah. Remember me?"
>> Take your
step up.
>> You say, "Mis."
>> All right. So, according to the verse,
>> according to the verse, does
>> he didn't curse. He didn't curse.
>> He didn't curse.
>> No, it's okay. So according to the
verse, can we agree? According to the
Bible at least, right?
>> The verse or the Bible?
>> That's it's in the Bible, bro.
>> I can say is God a man? No, he's
>> according according to the Bible. Yeah.
According it's in the Bible, bro.
>> Okay. So then I can say God is not a
man.
>> Okay, fine. So according to the Bible,
does Jesus know all things?
>> Okay, fine. Yeah.
>> Thank you. So this is why he knows the
hour. He knows everything. All things.
Jesus is omnisient demonstrating he has
he possesses the divine nature.
>> So why does he say everything I do is
through the father. Why does he what
does he mean by that when he says I of
the finger right the finger of
>> hey hey give me uh give me John five
>> John five.
>> Hey give me John five.
>> Hey what what's the only thing we do
around here brother?
>> That's it. Give me John five.
>> I keep reading man. Give me, give me,
give me, give me, give me, give me verse
19. Huh?
>> 19. So
>> Jesus said to them, "Truly, truly I say
to you, the son can do nothing of his
own accord." But
>> the son can do nothing of his own
accord. It's over for you Christians.
>> But oh, wait, hold on. Let's keep
reading.
>> But only what he sees the father doing.
For whatever the father does, the son
does likewise.
>> Wait, hold on a second, brother. Read
that one more time. The son can do
nothing of himself but but only what he
sees the father doing. For whatever the
father does, the son does likewise.
>> So according to what Jesus is saying, he
does nothing by himself. He can't work
alone. He can't work separately from the
father. However, whatever he does
>> that doesn't pertain to that's
irregardless of the nature. That's Jesus
himself.
>> That's Jesus himself. No, no, no. And
it's regard it is regardless of No,
because look now, let me tell you,
>> you're doing something you told me not
to do.
>> No, I'm telling you why this is ahead.
>> The reason why Jesus
cannot work apart from the father is
because by very nature they are
inseparable. You cannot split the son
and the father apart. So that's why he
says
>> split the father and
>> the son apart. Correct. So that part
that that means that the father is not
the son and the son is not the father.
>> Correct.
>> And the and the son is God and the
father is God. But there's only one God.
>> You got it. You got it. You got that.
You got a great cut. That's the trick.
Look. All right. You asked me a bunch of
questions.
>> I did.
>> Everybody listen up. Please. Please.
Everybody listen up. Please.
>> Please. Please. How many people are we
right here between the three of us?
Right. One, two, three. How many people
are we here, please? Three.
>> Three.
>> I can't say three.
>> How many people How many people are we
here?
>> Three. Three persons. Three people.
Right.
>> How many natures are there between the
three of us?
>> There's one human nature.
>> One human nature. Beautiful. Within the
trinity.
>> Yeah.
>> How many people are there in the
trinity?
>> How many persons there are? Three
persons.
>> No problem. How many persons are there
in the trinity?
>> Three. Three. You have the father,
>> the son, the holy spirit.
>> That's right.
>> These three are not each other just like
we are not each other. And these three
are three per three people.
>> He tripped up. Three people.
>> Three person.
>> Three persons. Three persons.
>> So you have three persons in the trinity
and we have three persons here.
>> Yep.
>> We have one nature here which is the
human nature and we have one godly
nature which is the godly nature of the
trinity.
>> Correct.
>> How many human beings are we here?
>> Oh there's So there's three different
human beings here.
>> Three different human beings. How many
godly beings are there in the trinity?
>> One.
>> Tell me how is that not symmetrical?
>> Because weed you committed an
equivocation fallacy. You were saying
persons and then you switched it to
being and they were defined differently.
That was a fallacy. What? No, no, no.
Absolutely. Three persons, one God, one
being, but three persons. Don't equate
being person. That was the that was the
fallacy. We just agreed that we are
three human beings with three different
persons and then uh that is one human
nature. Human nature. So with one human
nature,
>> why is it that with the trinity you look
at the trinity and you say there's three
persons and one nature and one
>> you have three persons, one human
nature, one human nature and you say you
don't say three human, three godly
beings like we say three human beings. I
can answer this for you. Okay.
>> Where why is there a sim? Why is there a
break in the same?
>> I'll tell you the difference. Okay. So,
his his question was a good question. We
are all of one human nature,
>> right? How is it that we are three
different human beings, but when we look
at the triune God, we say that these are
three persons. They are one nature. But
we only say that that's one divine
being. Why is that? Why? What's the
difference? The difference is being
Yeah. One one divine being. Here's the
difference. The difference is is that
the human nature can be split and
divided by space and time.
>> You and and I are separated by space and
time.
>> But so how would we not be separated by
space and time being one human being if
Yeah. If we if we were if we were one
human being that means that we wouldn't
be split time.
>> Exactly.
>> So then so then so then you're saying
that that is what's being applied to the
trinity. You're saying the son is not
being split in time with the father just
as just as we so that would mean that
they are each other.
>> No, it means that they are they share
the same being while being distinct
persons. Now, I think that what we need
to do is is make a distinction between
what a being is and then what personhood
is. Okay? So, for example, when we're
talking about being, we're talking about
what a thing is, its state of existence.
You understand what I'm saying? Um, when
we're talking about personhood, we're
talking about who a thing is. Okay? So
for example,
>> so what so what is the father?
>> God divine.
>> Who is the who is the father?
>> The father.
>> So that's the identity.
>> So same thing here.
>> What am I?
>> You're a human being.
>> Who am I? I'm Adam. Okay. Same thing.
>> And I'm a human being and I'm Avery.
We're two different human beings split
by space and time. Which means that we
are not the same human being. We're two
different ones.
>> So we're we're either going to be the
same human being or we're going to be
two different human beings.
>> Correct. either the same human being or
uh two different beings. Me the same
person, same human being.
>> No, not the same person. Why not?
>> Because look, so
>> why wouldn't he be the same person?
>> Let me show you. So for example, a rock.
A rock has beings. Correct.
>> A rock has beings. Sure. Okay. Cuz it's
existence.
>> Exactly. Because it's existent. Now,
here's my question. Is a rock a person?
>> Uh no.
>> Very good. So
>> because it doesn't have it doesn't have
a consciousness inside. Okay.
>> So notice we understand the difference
now between being your state of
existence and personhood. They're not
the same thing. Okay. So now let's go a
level up. Okay. Human beings. How many
human beings are there? As rough as
whatever 8 billion whatever,
>> right? 8 billion. Now how many persons
occupy each human being?
>> One person.
>> Exactly. So there's 8 billion different
human beings. And that mean and each
human being consists of one human
person. Now we're going a step further.
Let's go to God. How many divine beings
are there?
>> Of course, there's only one.
>> Only one. Now, what we're saying is
>> believe in three divine beings.
>> No, listen what I'm saying. We believe
in Listen, Adam, you got to hear me.
>> So, we believe in one divine being.
We're just saying that this being
consists of three persons. So, we just
acknowledge there's a difference between
being and personhood. So, when it comes
to God, he's one being that consists of
three persons. Unlike you and I, we only
consist of that's why they're three
persons.
>> But they Exactly. They are not each
other. One can think one thing, the
other can think another thing.
>> No, no, no. They have the same when
we're talking about being your thinking.
Your mind is of your essence. So they
have one mind, right? One mind, one one
will.
>> Does Does Jesus have the same will of
the father?
>> Absolutely.
>> So why does he ask the father to take
the cup away from me and knock it on the
cross?
>> Absolutely. So again, remember
>> No, no, no. Let let me clarify one more
time.
Why does Jesus ask the father which
they're supposed to have the same will
take this cup away from me I don't want
to go go on the cross basically is what
he's asking but of course at the end as
he is submissive to God he says not my
will but yours
>> yes
>> initially he does not want to go on the
cross why if they are supposed to have
the same will he not have the same will
there
>> I understand your question okay so
remember what I said mind and will is a
property of your essence your nature
your being okay so determining your
based on your being is the mind and will
that you have like no so bas I'm saying
that prop like uh will and like having a
will possessing a will possessing um um
a mind is a property of your essence
okay depending on your essence is your
will determine your mind and your will
right the reason why rocks don't have a
mind and will is because that's not a
property of a rock's state of existence
it's not a property of a rock's being to
have a mind and a will therefore it
can't have a person You get what I'm
saying?
>> So, okay. So, when it comes to your
will, right? Jesus has a will that he
has which is identical with the fathers
because he has let me let me let me tell
you why.
>> Because Jesus has a divine nature,
shares the same divine nature as the
father. He shares the same divine will
as the father. However, Jesus takes on a
human nature too. Meaning he has a
matter. Listen to what I'm saying,
brother. I'm saying that natures don't
do things. They just don't do things. So
watch what happens.
>> The person does things based on
correct. So So right here now when you
have here Jesus has a divine will
because he has a divine nature. So he
has a human nature and therefore has a
human will. This human will is what
you're seeing is him bringing under
subjection to the divine will that he
has equally with the father. So him
crying in the garden of Gethsemane when
he says let not my will be done but
yours is him bringing under subjection
that human will to the divine will that
he has with the father. You understand?
>> A couple minutes ago you said that it's
Jesus, right? We don't we don't say
Jesus's human nature or Jesus's divine
nature does XYZ,
>> right?
Is it true that Jesus in the garden of
Gethsemane initially in that uh in those
verses did not have the same will as the
father?
>> No. What? No. What you're dealing with
here is you're dealing with what Jes
Jesus pertaining to his human nature has
has a he's bringing subjection under
that will under the under the father's
will. So that's what I need you to like
try try to
>> I'm just going based off your standard.
When you told me don't don't flip-flop.
When you told me not to flip flop,
>> when did I flip flop? You just did by
saying no that's his that's his human
nature basically.
>> No I said Jesus is doing things
pertaining to his nature. What I'm
saying look natures are not going to act
without a person navigating that nature.
You know what I'm saying? So like for
example a will itself a will itself or a
person yeah a a nature itself can't
submit.
>> It's just a nature. But the person who
possesses that nature can submit. So
because he has a human nature, Jesus the
person brings that human will under
subjection to the divine will.
>> You understand what I'm saying?
>> So is it is it a false statement to say
Jesus when he says um uh take this cup
away from me basically I don't want to
get crucified when he says that that is
in is that in line or out of line with
the will of the father? It
>> it's it's it's it's as long as you
qualify it. If if you qualify as it in
line or out of line I'm answering your
question. If you're if you're qualifying
it saying you know uh that Jesus
pertaining to his human nature and his
human will is asking something that is
out of the father's will then you can
you qualify it pertaining to the human
nature because according to the human
nature according to especially the
scriptures it says that Jesus is going
to be a man of sorrows acquainted with
grief he's going to feel this pressure
he's going to grieve he's going to be
sorrowful so we we're not we shouldn't
be surprised when we see this in the
garden of Gethsemane him crying out to
God. If it's possible, let this cup pass
from me, but not my will that your will
be done. Now, here's the caveat. He
says,
>> that's what Muslims believe anyways.
>> No, it's not.
>> That's what that's what the
>> No, because he says, "Father,
>> not my will.
>> No, father, if not if it be possible."
>> And I and I granted that.
>> But then then you're not a Muslim.
>> Then you're not a Muslim.
>> No, that's not true. But that's in that
time.
>> My point. See, again, you cannot you
cannot just put Islam in a pocket of
culture. Islam is a is a religion
objectively.
Look, Islam is believing in one true God
just like Moses did and just like Jesus
did. Jesus when they asked Jesus, "What
is the most important commandment?" He
said, "Believe." He quoted Deuteronomy
6:4 and he said, "Uh, oh here Israel,
your Lord, your God is one, not three in
one."
>> Adam, there's something important. You
said to believe in what?
>> In one God.
>> But no, you said three in one God.
>> No, no. What did you say? To believe in
one what?
>> God. You said one true God, right?
>> Maybe I said it, maybe not. Regardless,
it's fine. I'll take it.
>> Okay. You said one true God.
>> Yeah. Just like John 17:3 says.
>> Okay. But listen to this. When you
acknowledge something is the truth, that
means it is objective across time,
culture, and opinion. It doesn't matter
what culture you're in. It doesn't
matter the time you live in. It doesn't
matter what you think. This is what it
is.
>> Let me ask you a question.
>> Wait, wait, wait. I got to I'm building
to something. So when you say that Islam
is believing in the one true God, that
means that this true God is a specific
deity who has Yes. All right. So that
means that the qualities of this God, if
you believe in anything outside of this,
then you are in the you're believing a
false god.
>> Of course. That's associating others
with God.
>> Exactly. So in Islam,
>> we don't associate others with God.
>> In Islam, you associate by saying the
father or by saying the Holy Spirit.
Jesus associate himself. Okay, but let's
do this for example. Oh, my bad. So,
let's do this for an example. Can you
say um I'm going to go perform salat in
the name of Allah and Jabril and
Muhammad. Can you ever say that?
>> I don't know what you're trying to say.
>> Can you ever say I'm going to perform
salat in the name of Allah and Jabril
and Muhammad? Could you ever make that
statement like that?
>> Who are you praying to?
>> You tell me. Allah Jabil Muhammad.
>> Allah. You're praying to Allah by
himself. So when I say in the name of
Allah Jill Muhammad I'm going to go
perform salat. Is that is that okay in
Islam?
>> Who are you praying to? I just asked you
a question.
>> Can you can you say that?
>> I just asked you.
>> Yeah. So so I said this. I'm going to go
pray to Allah in the name of Allah,
Jabil and Muhammad. Can you ever say
that?
>> I'm not sure. I don't think so. You got
to pray only. Yeah, of course I'm a
smart guy cuz I believe in the father
and I pray only to the one who Jesus
prayed to.
>> Who do you pray to?
>> I pray like Paul prays. 2 Corinthians
13:4
of the scripture. God knows the same
thing.
>> Can you ever make a claim like that as a
Muslim?
>> I just told you we pray only to the one
Jesus pray.
>> Can you make that statement?
>> I just told you we pray to God. We pray
to God and answer. We pray to Allah. We
pray we pray to Allah.
>> So you can't pray to Jabril and
Muhammad. Correct.
>> That's what he's asking.
>> Oh, that's not what he asked. But okay,
you cannot let me let me let me clarify
this. You cannot pray to Jabriel. You
cannot pray in his name. Let me let me
finish. You cannot pray to Muhammad. You
cannot pray to that statue right there.
Can you pray in their name?
>> You can only pray to the God of Jesus.
>> Thank you. Can you pray in their name?
>> You have to pray to God.
>> I'll ask it very simply again. Can you
or can you not pray in the name of
Jabriel and Muhammad and Allah? You have
to pray to God. So is that a no?
>> I just answered. Is that a no?
>> I just answered the question.
>> Is that a no?
>> I literally answered you. You have to
pray only to God.
>> Brother, I don't understand your answer.
Is a I need a yes or no.
>> I'm I'm going to answer you. Look, I I
already answered you and I'm going to
continue answering.
>> It's a yes or no, please.
>> It's very simple. Who did Jesus?
>> It's a yes or no.
>> Who did I already I already answered
you,
>> Adam? I literally answered.
>> Can you Can you do any Can you perform
any religious right in anybody's name
other than Allah? Yes or no?
>> Say that one more time. Can you perform
any religious rights like prayer, jihad,
uh fasting, zakat, can give charity? Can
you do any of these things in the name
of anyone other than Allah?
>> Unless Allah commands if Allah commands
you to do it. That's it.
>> We we have to be we have to be obedient
to God. If God tells you to do
something, you got to do it. But at the
end of the day, you have to pray to the
one true God, the one that Jesus prayed
to. If if if if you did these things in
the name of other things other than
Allah, would that be associating
partners with Allah?
>> If Allah told me not to, if Allah didn't
tell me to do that, then yes.
>> Okay. So my question is, if you did
that, would that be associating a
partner with Allah?
>> I just answered the question.
>> You did not. You said, "If Allah tells
me to do it, I can. If he doesn't tell
me, I cannot." I didn't ask you that.
I'm asking, is the action itself
associating a partner?
>> That's like me saying, "Is God a man?"
Just answer the question. The same
thing.
>> Answer the question.
>> How can I How can I say this? Okay, it's
like this. Um, if I put my hands
together and it makes a noise, what is
that called?
>> It's a clap.
>> Okay. If Allah says don't clap, does
that mean it's not a clap anymore?
>> What do you mean?
>> If Allah says don't clap, you're no
longer allowed to clap. It's haram to
clap. Does that mean when I put my hands
to together and it makes a noise, is
that no longer a clap because it's now
haram?
>> No, that's a clap.
>> Okay. So, it's still a clap. It's just
forbidden, right?
>> Yeah, sure.
>> Okay. So we notice we identified the
action but I'm asking you not if the
action is allowed. I'm asking you about
the action itself. Okay
>> that matters.
>> I I know I know my question is this. If
I were to do something in the name of
somebody other than Allah, did I just
associate a partner with Allah?
>> Are you are you telling me to answer it
whether
>> irregardless of whether God tells you or
not to tell you?
>> Correct.
>> All right then. Yes.
>> Thank you. So now if God if Allah tells
you to do it then it's just you're
allowed to make a partner with him. But
>> command to what do you mean to make a
partner?
>> If Allah allows you to do it if he
allows you
>> who says that's making a partner.
>> You you just did
>> how did I just what did you say?
>> You just said that. You just said
regardless of if Allah allows it or not
doing something in the name of someone
other than Allah is associated and
partner with him.
>> No. I thought you were asking me if I
can do that. I was saying yes
>> brother. My question is clear. All
right. I'll I'll say it again.
regardless of if Allah allows it or does
it is the action of doing something in
the name of someone other than Allah is
that sherk is
>> no not necessarily no
>> so I can do things in the name of other
people I can perform salat in the name
of Jabriel I can perform charity in the
name of Muhammad and it's I'm not
associating a partner with Allah
>> if Allah commands it
>> but he did watch your head watch your
head watch your head watch your head.
Watch your head.
>> Never go fuller.
>> I'm a Muslim just as much as Jesus was
not asking. We're asking we're asking
how Islam works.
>> We're asking how Islam works. Currently
in Islam, can you pray in the name of
Muhammad? Can you pray in the name of
Jabrel? In Islam now,
>> I already answered. I already answered
answered. Yes or no?
>> I literally answered.
>> You didn't answer that question. I
literally answered. in Islam now can you
pray in the name of Muhammad? I I
literally if I answer this question,
you're going to answer mine.
>> Yes, I already answered it. If Allah
come if Allah commands you to do
something, you do it simply.
>> That's not giving me a yes or no.
>> Associate that doesn't necessarily mean
you're associating partner.
>> But can you now in the current religion
of Islam pray in the name of Muhammad?
>> You have to pray to Allah.
>> Yes or no?
>> It's very You have an objective standard
for truth. You have an objective
standard for truth.
>> You're trying Listen, we're not trying
to get a gotcha here. We're asking you
how things look I'm a truth seeker%
I'm trying to be honest here in Islam
this is what this is what I'm trying to
figure out
>> in Islam you cannot pray in the name of
Muhammad
>> that's the point we're getting at you
cannot be in the name of Muhammad
>> he needs to admit that if he can't admit
that we can't go any further no of
course we can go any further the
question is this
not the question the question is who was
Jesus
>> can you pray to anybody can you pray in
the name of Muhammad Yes or no?
>> If Allah commands, I mean it's that
simple.
>> But he didn't command.
>> Can you command it?
>> No.
>> To me, no.
>> Okay. So, can you do it?
>> Okay. Thank you. So, you cannot do that.
So, you can can Now, here's my other
question. Can you do anything? Can you
uh do zakat? Can you uh give charity?
Can you fast? Can you uh uh perform
dash? Can you do any of these things in
the name of Muhammad or Jabir or anybody
else other than Allah? Yes or no? If the
if the Quran or the I'm going to answer
I'm gonna answer. I'm gonna answer. If
the Quran or the Sunnah tells you to do
it in his name, then you do it in his
name.
>> Does it?
>> Honestly, I don't know. I just
I'm going to say something. Let me say
something. I'm going to say something.
>> As God is my witness. Cuz I believe in
God. As God is my witness. As God is my
witness. I'm not lying. I honestly don't
know if it says innah.
>> Okay. Thanks.
Um, if uh, no problem. I'm not sure. I
don't know. What I know is this. What I
know is this. Praying to the one true
God. That's what I know.
>> What I know is that. And when Jesus says
he's going to his father, your father,
my God, your God, that's the God who we
believe in.
>> All right. Let me respond to this. Okay.
>> Which God?
>> That what? We're 40 minutes. Okay. We'll
uh we'll wrap this up here.
>> Spoke for 40 minutes.
>> Yeah. This look
if you're saying that you didn't know
>> on on God as God is my witness right
now. I don't know.
>> So that that would
>> I'm I'm I'm assuming you're going to
pull maybe from the assume I'm not
I was I was hoping cuz I I
>> I would my answer is always going to be
people
respect. Yeah. Just I'm just saying
honestly like every every Muslim would
know the answer is no. But I can't I
can't say that you're every Musl you're
not every Muslim. So, if you didn't know
this, that would explain your resistance
to answer straight away. But you should
have just said that, bro. You should
have just said, "You know what? I don't
know the answer to that." That
don't please. You didn't ask me. You
didn't ask me. You're You are You are
wearing my patience. Please. I look
listen to what I'm saying, Adam. Listen
to what I'm saying. I asked you a
straight question. I asked you, "Can you
do any of these things in the name of
someone other than Allah?" Your answer
was not, "I don't know." Your answer was
well if the Quran or Sunna says it then
maybe then yeah you can but if not then
no that wasn't an answer but but really
you didn't know if the Quran said this
or not. So your answer So your answer to
me should have been, "Hey, bro, I don't
know." That's what that would have saved
us some time. So we spent like 15
minutes asking you the same question and
everybody's frustrated off of this, bro.
>> Look, they can they can be frustrated.
The point is this. The the God the God
of Jesus is the one the God of Jesus is
the one that I pray to.
>> Let me No, you don't. No, you don't.
>> Well, do you believe Jesus had a God?
>> Let me tell you why this. No.
>> Did Jesus have a God?
>> Let me tell you why you don't pray to
the same one. Because Jesus said this.
He said, "Go out and baptize in the
name, one name, singular, in the name of
the Father, the Son, and the Holy
Spirit."
>> My question is this. Did Jesus just
associate himself and the Holy Spirit
with the father in that statement?
>> I'm not sure.
>> What I know I know what I know is this.
>> What I know is this.
>> Watch your head, man. I know what that
means.
>> What I What I know is this. The God of
Jesus is the one that we pray to. No,
it's not. It's very simple. The one that
Jesus prayed to. Yes, I believe in the
father. No problem.
>> You don't believe in the father? No
problem. We don't we Jesus didn't pray
to the holy spirit.
>> You're you're you're assuming
>> you you pray to the god of Jesus. Okay.
Jesus told us how to pray to god. He
said we have to taugh us. He said
>> Jesus told us how to pray. He said, "We
say, Our Father, who art in heaven, be
thy name, thy kingdom come, thy will be
done on earth as it is in heaven.
Forgive us this day of our trespasses.
Forgive us of our sins as we forgive
those who disgu and lead us not to
temptation."
>> Can I say something?
>> Can I say something? Can I say something
to that? Can I say something? Do you not
say, "Father,
>> can I say something to that?"
>> Do you pray to the father?
>> Amen.
>> Okay.
You're not a Muslim.
>> I pray for the one you just prayed to.
>> You're a Muslim.
>> Guys, guys, he just said amen to that.
So, Adam, congratulations. You left the
>> one. Look, I'm tired. I know you got to
rap. I know you got Let me say my last
name.
>> I know. I know. I got to rap. Let me Let
me say my last thing. Let's pray.
>> Let's pray. I have no problem praying.
>> Let's pray. Let's pray.
>> As long as As long as I lead it.
Are we praying to the one that Jesus
prayed to?
>> You believe you believe that that's the
father has a begotten son's pray.
>> What do you mean?
>> Yeah, we'll do the Lord's prayer
together.
>> Okay, no problem. I have no problem. Our
father pray
and then we'll pray the father's
>> cuz I know you got to rap. What I'm
saying is at the end of the day, the one
that Jesus prayed to, the one that he
bowed his head down to, the one he
always seek help from, the one he gained
knowledge from, that one being in his
language is Allah Aramaic. Sure.
Yeah, no problem. And in and and and in
Arabic it's Allah. That's the one we
pray to. Like it's it's very simple.
That's the one we pray to. That is
>> I got you.
>> But we'll wrap it up.
>> We want to pray together.
>> So he wants to pray together, guys. So
we're going to pray together.
>> We're going to pray.
>> Ready? So you're going to say this.
You're going to say No, we're going to
say it first, guys.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. So we're going to say
it first and you repeat after us. Okay.
>> What I'm going to do is I'm going to
pray to Allah. No. You're going to
repeat the pray. Can we pray to Allah?
>> No. You're going to pray to our father.
>> Can I pray to Allah?
>> No. Our father. Listen. You want to
pray? You want to pray like
we're going to pray our father?
>> You You wouldn't say Allah is God.
>> No, I'm going to say the father's God.
Say it with me. The father's God.
>> Would you say Allah is God?
>> No.
>> Say the father's God.
>> Would you say we got to close?
>> So, are you going to Are you going to
pray with us?
>> I'm being I'm being straight.
>> Are you going to pray with us?
>> I have no problem praying.
>> Okay. So, so repeat after me. Our
father.
>> Are we going to pray to the God of
Jesus?
>> Yes.
>> Yes. Yes. We'll pray to the God of
Jesus.
>> So, our father,
>> look, what we're going to do is we're
going to pray to God.
>> Our father,
>> look, what we're going to do,
>> brother. I'm not I'm done wasting my
time, man. If you want if you want to
pray with us, then let's pray. If not, I
got other people that want to talk.
>> I have no problem praying to I have no
problem praying to
>> I got you. You said that already. You
ready?
>> That's what I'm saying.
>> Okay. You ready?
>> No problem saying that.
>> Are you ready?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Repeat after me. Dear God. Our
father.
>> Dear God.
>> Our father. Dear God. All right. That's
it. Hey, brother. Hey, I appreciate it
you coming. It was this was a good
conversation, man. Let's clap it up.
>> It's all about respect.
>> Yeah, I respect you for sure. You
stepped up braver than a lot of people
that don't step up. So, what's up,
brother? All right.